in just the past few weeks multiple
foreign terrorist organizations have
called for attacks against Americans and
the West the FBI director Ry nor the
president have any idea whether or not
there is somebody from Hamas uh roaming
around the United States of America who
could strike this kind of deadly attack
on our own
country all right you notice a pattern
here more and more uh Governors and the
fact the governor of Oklahoma and Texas
who were visiting Israel to warn us
what's going on over there and the
threat of Terror over there is in fact
likely to happen over here Christopher
Ray the FBI director saying as much just
a few days earlier Chris Wecker is the
former FBI assistant director Chris good
to have you are they right is it just a
matter of time before we're dealing with
with what Israel's dealing with
here absolutely Neil I mean this is the
the the greatest terrorist terrorist
threat to this country since the pre-
911 runup
and I think it's even more more
pronounced now because we have these
conflicts these these cells in the
United States I mean when I say sales I
mean Hezbollah and Hamas but mostly
Hezbollah have been around for a long
long time raising money committing
crimes and raising money for Hezbollah
those cells could quickly morph into
violent cells and with the southern
border being as open as it is we have no
idea who's in this country so it's a
combination of of what's going on in the
Middle East as well as that wide openen
Southern border we got to have couple
hundred FBI agents on that border trying
to to determine who's coming in we have
completely negated all the security uh
steps that we took after 911 to keep
terrorists out of this country so the
fear is there already here Chris and
then the question becomes uh the added
inspiration of this Hamas activity
against Israel started four weeks ago
this very day and I'm just wondering
because that's how Christopher Ray
framed it that they would take
inspiration from that and follow up on
that in what
way clearly I mean that's we've seen
this over the years where a lone
terrorists here's the call they they
operate uh semi-independently in the
sense that they're not card carrying
Hezbollah or card carrying Hamas or
Al-Qaeda or Isis but then there's also
the the greater threat I think of
organized terrorist activity in the US
yes these cells were already here but
there's even more flowing across our
border every day without question and we
don't know where they are or who they
are it's if if you're a terrorist you're
going to sneak across that southern
border you don't need to take a plane or
use any other means to get into this
country and they can come in in groups
and cells they often get mistaken for
being Hispanic if they actually do go
through a border crossing but most of
them don't they go around the border
crossings and come in illegally with the
help of the cartels which is another
scary
Alliance we're waiting in the meantime
Chris before Anthony Lincoln our
secretary of state he's meeting with a
number of Arab leaders his counterparts
foreign ministers and the from the likes
of of Jordan and Egypt Saudi Arabia what
have you uh when it comes to those
Representatives with whom he's chatting
to a man they seem to be saying uh go
slow Israel cool it on what you're doing
at the border yet we discover that Hamas
wounded Fighters are sneaking in on
these ambulances and getting out of the
country so many of them might have
already left the country then it begs
the question to do
what to do bad things I mean I was I was
the FBI's onse commander in Iraq and we
were investigating bombings throughout
the theater targeting civilians
primarily and the Hand of of uh Iran was
all over these bombings and when you see
what 500 pounds of high explosives and
what that can do it wakes you up to the
level of commitment because that suicide
bomber is planning on going out himself
S as well I saw bom a Red Cross and and
other facilities the UN there are no
boundaries for these people and they are
dedicated to destroying the western
civilization as we know it so you you
know they're in it for the long haul
yeah and you can't I guess the point
being Neil you can't trust them no
matter what they say you cannot trust
them in the meantime we have this policy
of going after and beefing up our troop
presence I believe mostly in Syria I
think we're up to 12200 troops if memory
serves me right Chris and it's meant to
attack these Iranian funded proxies that
have been behind 28 29 attacks over the
last couple of weeks but as I've
mentioned with a couple of other guest
course never Iran itself and the fear is
obviously you go after Iran itself the
war has expanded dramatically uh but
Iran's already doing that and Iran is
already anticipating our reticence to
expand um so they keep doing that so
what's the
answer yeah I mean it's my belief that
Iran already has nuclear capabilities
and you know they've been lying to us
all along so we we're dealing with a
nuclear power here so I can understand
why we're going to hit the proxies why
we're going to nibble around the edges
that I don't think that Iran understands
that when when Trump hit uh solomani
that sent the right message and I think
we need to take those types of measures
that are dramatic not just you know as I
said nibbling around the edges of it we
need to send a clear message we don't
have to evade Iran we don't have to do
what we did in Iraq Afghanistan but we
need to hit some really high value
targets even if they are in Iran because
they know they don't have the capability
to go up against the United States we
still are the great the the world's
greatest P military power but we have to
send a clear dramatic message much like
the solomani hit Chris thank you very
much Chris Wecker the former FBI
assistant director he's been In Harm's
Way all his life dealing with this and
seeing it firsthand hi everyone I'm
Brian kilme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to sub subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now